is now fixed and anna we're looking at
uh or trying to look at layla's game
in the women's event leila yeah
against gina
so let's see if we can pull our game up
here we are
oh
yeah you have it and i don't know if it
was heard or not but i said that it's a
very interesting position is in this
game bishop d2 being the last move
and look at that white is a pawn down
but there is no director of bishop so
black skin is in some danger
though there is a possibility of
knight f3 move is she preparing to
sacrifice a queen
i think she is
she doesn't have any other options she
will take
take
take this one
and now we need to think
we need to think there is bishop c3
bishop e2 yes
maybe bishop e2
uh queen f5
the only move
it looks like
e5 is possible
nice move
and take the knight or maybe there is
even something better
this looks uh
like it should be winning for white
doesn't it
this should be winning for white so
maybe black can't go into this
uh what can black do
yeah bishop takes h3
i just try
bishop takes h3 look at that move
leaving the queen now
if y takes now we play knight of three
and our rook is protected so i think
white needs to attack on e4 we take back
then the queen moves somewhere and we
take something
somewhere we take something
yeah there's a nice checkmate for
example if queen b4 or other moose and
black can check mate in two right if
queen b4 took on h3 knight f3 check do
you want to show that anna if queen b4
uh sorry at the ends
uh quintin before yeah then of course
knight f3 check okay
king and checkmate there we go
um
she has made a move
shoot you now
um bishop takes h3 wow
astonishing
no i don't see any other options but
what a game
has she played it yeah she played bishop
h3 i saw it on the camera i see
so i think kirk should
white should take uh knight takes this
might have to take anna yeah i don't see
any other
so the black strokes are now connected
so the point is that if bishop takes h3
then knight f3 check
um
works
the rook on a8 defends the rook on e8
very important yeah it just wins
so we're looking at rook takes
queen
if bishop takes h3 on here
i guess knight takes bishop takes
how would this be
what do we think about this
so white has the bishop pair um two
bishops for a rook and two pawns
this could happen couldn't it yeah of
course
maybe rook d8
maybe rook t8 it's possible yes and then
picking up the knights on d1
because i believe that in this position
it's good for black to try to trade one
pair of rocks
let's have a quick look rook 88
forcing an exchange of
rooks
yeah i think white should take because
if y takes on e5 or d6 bishop d6 or k1
then should we get on c1 and it's better
for white to have the bishop on e5
rather than on d6 so from e5 it's uh
protecting the b2 pawn okay so rook
takes takes takes six takes check
king up i don't know
king g2 let's see maybe bishop f1 and
kenji
too uh harika ended her game with
elizabeth and we see a draw
drawing that game right okay well that
was really the most that elizabeth could
achieve from that position so um yeah
she did well she held
good result for her um
obviously a win was uh
what she would have liked at the start
of the game but from that position the
draw was really the best that she could
hope for which she's achieved so um
keeps among the top
ranked players here
and we're looking at leila
yeah she took the queen
knight x rook
very sharp middle game here
i like this game yeah
that's great how did they enter all
these complications so
ah here is the moment to where
black sacrifice a pawn first okay queen
biscuit all right so she played a4 and
queen e5 right
uh yeah here a3 going to c4
knight c1 and to consist three
wow bishop f1 queen e4 queen c3 knight
e5
and bishop d2 bishop s3 tremendous game
of chess this one really a
fantastic
knight six e4 queen attacked rook to
rook attacked
some of those moves for the queen allow
checkmate after knight f3 check
we said maybe bishop takes h3 here and
just give back
the queen
anything else unless you could do here
could
is a move like queen e3 possible or not
what would happen queen e3
[Music]
there is knight g4 there is i mean 96
bishop f1
it's um it's certainly complicated
that she hugely knows down to about 10
minutes and layla still has
more or less half an hour on her clock
very complex game okay the simplest is
to take on d6 if y takes on h3 i play
knight c4 then i take on d and you
recover the place
yes and it looks good for black
i think you're absolutely right yes
so maybe white should play bishop h3 and
then go for this end game which we saw
before yeah yeah which i think is
more or less equal because a bishop
player
against
two bishops against rook and two pawns
all right
[Music]
anna maybe we should drop back in on the
open game the top open games
quite a lot has happened i believe in
maxim's game against
fabi and also david howell
we come to him as well against alireza
and they already reached an end game
wow
let's just very quickly take us through
the moose
from this position which we more or less
saw
take takes uh queen to b3 rook e1 queen
d3
queen takes seven
pick exchanges
and now white
one
a pawn white is a pawn up indeed after
i've said this is the current position
but
the drawing chances are very hard
um
i don't know rookie six or or bring
their back because if you play rook is
seven there is rook d8
simply wins the pawn
so
but rook six doesn't help much i think
this uh
just
check
yeah and
no i mean to f8
and then after
this should be just checking
[Music]
seems to be quite relaxed they're
walking uh
okay it's very close to drawing d8 or d2
then
activate the rook
oh well i
i'm expecting this game to to finish
quite soon as a draw right yes
well that certainly suits uh fabi more
than it suits maxim
no question
i agree
and it looks like maxim about to make a
move or has made a move rather
i think they have already played more
than 100
times rook f5 he played
f5
that's nikita vittugo as well in in shot
and how is david holding against alireza
there we see the two players poor one of
course
so things have happened here they've
been at least
an exchange of some pawns
after c4
david took on c4 and played d5 very
sharp very confident approach
bishop d3 e takes d4 okay something is
happening in this game
finally
so if knight d4
i think black wanted to take on e4 it's
my first person
also c5
c5 maybe maybe looks
hard to believe but what happens if you
take c4 let's have a look at that d
takes c4
it takes
black keeps trading i suppose
that looks
i agree
well bishop d5 there is it possible
but um
don't like it for black
well
i wouldn't say i like it
i wouldn't go that far
david by the way is down to inside 15
minutes now
and alireza with 42 minutes or so on his
clock how many moves have they played
anna
23 23.
and as we can see it's
a complex
complex middle game
i think why should be better here i can
just take a look at
c5 here
wow c5 okay yeah you mentioned that
it feels very loose but uh
we'll come back
it should be better for what
we'll leave around there on move and uh
i think we now have peter douglas who
has something to share with us so pete
over to you
yeah
another example uh from one of the
a nice
moment in
the game on board 47 between
two players with quite a bit of a h gap
we have 55 year old kirill gyorgyev from
bulgaria playing 15 year old kukashidi
from
from india
one of the
biggest gaps
possible almost in this in this field i
think
and
it's interesting uh first for a night
maneuver
which i actually learned when you need
to checkmate with bishop and knight
against the lone king that the knight is
following the shape of a w if you have
never heard of that you could
google it of course and there's lessons
on that also on chess.com this knight on
b3 is is going to make a w as well there
is knight c5 here queen g4 knight to d3
where we would call it an octopus
from the famous 16th match game carp of
cospire of one of the most famous
octopus games i would recommend
playing through that one as well if you
don't know it yet here
the octopus doesn't stay on d3 for long
because we still have to finish the w
to e5 with tempo
and here
knight f3 check so
b3 c5 d3 e5 f3
and
white could not take
with the pawn
because then there would follow queen g5
king h1
takes threatening mate
takes and queen h4
threatening mate on h2 and
it's all over so in the game
white decided to take with the knight
but after pawn takes
taking back would lead to another
disaster so white went queen to c4 but
after
takes rookie one and now the nice move
bishop f3
black is in full control and
actually this position is also minus
five almost minus six according to the
engine so gucash the younger player is
going to beat the uh veteran player here
in riga back to islands too
and thank you pete for that it's a very
instructive so knight b3 c5 d3 e5 f3
what a manual what a maneuver yeah in
consecutive moves
really quite something that and looks
like black will be winning um from that
position which you saw
great um
ali reza here on top board hasn't yet
moved on so um that's still the position
but bishop d7 has been played sorry
bishop d7 we hadn't seen that's right
bishop b6 to d7
white to play
now there are of course many
possibilities but the first ones i'm
considering are
a nigita f5 knights d2 f5
with the idea of
coming to d6 coming to d6 and also
possible
sacrifices on g7 or h6
so maybe you can take a look at
all this move
okay
knight f5 now
the threat is knight d6 as you say
well if black doesn't want to give up
the exchange
um
what should he do what about let's try
bishop takes f5
knight takes
there's also the queen a4 of course may
also come into
my consideration now for white
if that moves
so what
should uh what should black do here i
wonder
queen d7 maybe
still
complex
might be careful black
i think it's better for white
after e takes d5
e65
and then
knight takes a space
then and then just bishop somewhere
right
yeah not sure
maybe you take it the knight f4 hmm
it does look dangerous doesn't it with
the knights on f5 though
maybe black's okay
oh yeah black can only be tactical okay
because strategically this is weak this
is weak also some robots on g7
uh what else do we have after knight f5
black can wait and not take on f5 maybe
some bishop c7 move
right
let's check yeah protecting on a4
stops 96. stops 96. now white has to
decide what to do with this pawn because
it's under the attack if
y takes now then 95 and
there we see maxim
[Music]
against fabiani yeah maybe we can
check what happened
uh rook f5 rb8 d6 takes takes and drop
the toyota just should be a draw
or not
how to make it
in the most careful way
not sure actually
king g6
d7
it's not so easy is it
maybe can f8 d7h5
king f8
uh then bring the king to f5 is also
possible
i mean black's gonna have to defend the
three against tuesday on the king's side
you shouldn't be so difficult you should
be all right here
still not over yet
or king g6 rook d7 the same then you
played h5 followed by king f5
something along those lines
he looks uh calm doesn't he fabby
yeah he always looks calm
never in trouble he needs to get this
absolutely right there
okay let's check some lines if i akin to
f8 d7
let's say h5 we are preparing d5 and
kidney 7.
so
white has to do something
now
if h4 or
maybe
okay h4 might be g5 anyway
yeah that's right yeah g5 and king
king up
so if
roxy
ate kenny seven
rugged
[Music]
so maybe h4
okay
looks like he's about to make his played
king f8 right
and gets up from the table you get the
feeling that he knows what he's doing
here anna
that he can
more or less see his way to
a draw
it's very likely this game will be ended
in a draw
should we have a quick look at some
alexey sheriff's game for example and
also in the kit of the twogov's game
uh here we have nikita golf game
this was the crazy game where white
played knight d4
and then very com committal with d6
so nikita played rugby one queen d7
bishop g4 and here he sacrificed a pawn
okay
and another one is under attack
indeed
d6 is attacked he can take on g7 i think
that's what he will do
now there's knight e3 and try to take on
f6 of course with his rook
what about knight e3 so i didn't see
here yeah exactly sorry 93.
queen d3 this
this
[Music]
rook f8
well at least he has a five for his
knights if he needs it
sorry he has the f5 square for his
knight
yeah but he's exchanged i know yeah it's
all these adventures the nice thing
going around uh
um
okay if he doesn't want to sacrifice an
exchange can
can he do anything else i think it's the
best chance
otherwise the deep launch is false
and then the e pawn is also weak
as well
maybe queen g4
right okay yeah
queen g4 attacks the jeep on with the
queen
maybe rook g8 yeah
no queen h5
okay now you don't have g6
because of queen h7 check yeah but you
can take on d6 with the knight and i
don't have attack okay this
this is just bad
what about d7 here on a under the knight
e3 now d7 yeah d7
and what did you plan after 93 well i
didn't plan anything but
yeah i just did not check i would like
to do that
sure
let's just let's just do it d8
why not
okay
let's say i am surprised
but i have to continue
uh 187 right kind of six takes
takes
and black should be better in this
energy
sure
queen takes e4 here right
yeah well very good no even the end game
like the rook end game is better for
black
there we see on our screens uh le
tingxie
playing um your sister maria there top
board
in the ladies section
and are they about to
hit
agree a draw maybe
okay i think luckily for maria the rooks
are off
and uh yeah this looks uh quite safe so
yeah after g5 i believe they all trade
everything in degree
advantage foreign uh white could try to
go for more okay
make a draw i also understand latin yeah
finish it finish completely good work
look sort of raise your eyebrows they
haven't agreed a draw
we have a winner of the uh
chess.com women's grounds grounds ground
swiss so it's one round to go congr
big congratulations
yeah
fantastic results amazing performance
and
getting the spot to the candidates oh
maria said something maybe maybe she
congratulates also
eight and a half points out of ten
absolutely amazing
and uh it would be very nice if we could
have uh perhaps a few words with
latinxie we'll see if we can manage that
yeah i think she wouldn't be against the
country
so tell us a little bit more about how
she feels
but very very and look that's nice the
officer congratulations
very nice indeed
thoroughly deserved victory in this
tournament and
around before the end as well
yeah
uh okay now we are going for a short
break uh let's hope we'll have an
interview as late in chia so stay tuned
and
we will be back shortly
the new chess.com events page has
arrived
find all the games from top tournaments
around the world as well as
championships played right here on
chess.com
explore each game and even vote on who
you think will win their matchups
review standings schedules key
information and find links to all the
top news surrounding each event
head to chess.com events today and
experience your favorite tournaments
like never before
[Music]
so
welcome back to our live broadcast here
from riga at the grand swiss and we have
a special guest with us latin jay who
just drew her game with mariam music and
with that draw
won the tournament in the women's
section the inaugural women's grand
swiss congratulations on your victory
thank you very much
uh how are you feeling right now
uh
okay this game i tried to play fojo and
but my opponent i think
she
forgot some lines because uh rook c6
instead of btx66 and i think queen b7
and queen c6 quincy 8 and this must be
uh
um george so but
she played btx and i
i thought okay this position i can't
lose it so i
wanted to play and i just want to enjoy
playing chess but yeah it seems you have
a more comfortable position yeah so
so right now i'm a little confused about
it because
i don't know
the end game
is good for me or just no chance
but but you didn't want to risk it you
just went for a draw and obviously to
secure it to secure your your first
place in the tournament
uh we're around to spare how will you be
playing tomorrow obviously uh
you won so how would you approach
tomorrow's game
okay the tournament is still playing so
i will try my best in the last round
because
i would like to have a good memory in
rika
well with a score like this
i mean so far it's great
obviously your performance is amazing as
well it's over 2800
how has this affected your personal
confidence
and how do you feel
okay i think this tournament
is a good opportunity to
exercise myself and
i think this time i learned a lot
in riga and
i also get some confidence from this
tournament so
i'm quite happy about it what would you
say were the key lessons learned
in this tournament for you
because i think this tournament
you can say it's maybe a wonderful
tournament for me but i think
the second game i i think i had a bad
position and
when i played against her with
[Music]
i think the sixth round and
i was in time trouble and i made some
big mistakes and but
after 40 moves and i thought i recovered
from it and i think that game was very
very important and i won that one and
then play against nino and
she made some
bad decisions when that game i think
maybe this tournament
it's coming like
maybe i can
i can win this tournament all right so
the tournament went your way and
obviously tomorrow's just a formality i
just need to ask you this there's twenty
thousand dollars of prize money what are
you gonna do with it you have any idea
oh
no idea because uh
i don't care about it
when you get it you'll think about it
all right well thank you so much
congratulations once again and uh good
luck with the candidates thank you very
much
thank you back to you anna
milan thank you very much and there we
see latinxi
and a
thoroughly deserved victory in this
[Music]
women's ground swiss and a really
fantastic performance and she gets the
candidate's place
so
i'll meet her there
but maybe also some tournaments before
the candidates so yeah congratulations
to latin gm amazing performance
uh wonderful games and yeah she also
shared her thoughts on today's game and
how she feels oral about the tournament
and about her success
now we see um we'll just catch up with
one or two of the other women's games
and then go back to the
open uh on our screens we see this game
between leila javakishvili
and i'm sorry we did
yeah i just wanted to come back to
maxim's game okay
this rook ending
so what happened kin f8 rook d7 g5
i he started with g5 maybe it's more
precise to start with g5 indeed
then
h5 h4
okay
okay i don't really expect any other
result in a draw in this game what do
you think uh fabi will do now
he can take an h4 black in it
okay okay
white will take the spawn on h5 maybe
not even
so easily taking on h5
what let's say takes takes
rook h7
now black can
even try to
play a rook d5 but
the simplest is just to take on d6 will
be simply still black in f7 and he will
hold this of course yeah
okay so fabian is steering this game we
believe towards a draw
and
what about the top board game anna
how did they come there so
it takes d4 and i def 94 bishop d7
then knight f5 was played but another
knight okay
yeah i wasn't sure like okay if knight
f5 or knight d2 f5 is better knight
d2f5 makes sense because this knight on
g3 is protecting the e4
so bishop to c7 anyway right
why takes in d5 c takes d5 couldn't he
take with the knight
maybe he could but he decided sure
bishop d5 and a bishop d5 yeah bw4
bishop e5
that is the current position
and david
hall with less than 10 minutes
meanwhile alireza has 25 or 26 minutes
this looks quite pleasant for white
isn't it if you take on a5
uh rook e5 maybe even queen d2 first but
okay let's take a look at that
yeah okay
but some
white must have other moves and as well
as taking on e5 he could uh
any way he could strengthen his position
what about doubling rooks on the
sea lion maybe no
okay
yeah just i don't know maybe yeah
rookie 2c2
don't know
one among many options
um for white
we can check your bishop take c5 as well
on there let's have a look bishop take
c5
there are so many moves to consider
david is already under 10 minutes yeah
so he's again in a time trouble no
surprise hmm
yeah and um
okay also queen iran looks interesting
yeah we should be one maybe these kinds
of miss yeah we should be one
how about that we should be one so that
the queen also
covers d4
though we're not going to take on d4
with the queen
so it's um
a rich
position i would say many uh
many possibilities
kind of safe for black as well maybe at
the moment
or what if queen f1
takes yeah no then we have to cover the
visual
so if bishop takes e5 what will david do
he'll play rook takes 20 because of
knight
with the rock with the book okay
now
well again rook e to c2 maybe it's too
um
let's see if it's not important i didn't
but then better to play
e2c2 immediately you know
before
a bishop takes c5
here black hat circuit
all right yeah
all right well um yeah let's try
something else i didn't know
it doesn't look too bad for like these
positions
i mean okay black has the isolated
queen's pawn might has the d4 square but
i mean apart from that
yeah there's always some contrabler with
knight f4 or knight e4 yep
still looks pretty uh
solid for black
okay
i predict lots of lots of drama still to
come in this uh this position especially
as david
maybe gets shorter time what's been
played a night moved somewhere
what was the move something tactical
maybe knight to
did we miss something
knight to h6 or what
which move did we miss
knight takes h6 check
goodness me
well that's drama certainly
he wants to take on g6 he wants to take
on g6
if bishop d4 he takes here
it's actually a bit strange that we
didn't even see that
didn't see it
and i wonder if david saw it
so once again if g takes h6 it's hard to
think of anything else bishop will take
the knights
and now black c5 bishop is hanging
and if bishop takes d4 queen takes d4
attacks the knight on f6
this more or less forced
white has won a pawn and also black's
king is uh
clearly
weaker than it was
so maybe it's not so solid not so solid
a tactical shot there for mali reza
knight
takes h6 check
i actually have got an update that
engine considers that instead of knight
h6
rook takes e5 is even stronger rook
takes a fire i actually considered that
more but i
didn't calculate any lines after that
and after 95 then 96 d6 recovering the
exchange
and um
the queen doesn't have that many squares
to go to actually
knight six e8
knight black captures with the bishop
say or queen okay
yeah of course y's position is more
pleasant but
after knight h6 white won a pawn and
here
david has played gtx h6
i'm just trying to understand why uh
where the engine
thinks that uh
this is better than
the move on the resume because i think
that the knight 86 from practical point
of view is stronger bishop takes g6
and it's david's move
now what is the best defense here
and david with seven and a half minutes
on his clock
now the wrestler still has 22
minutes or so
and
this is where
not just the position but time is also
critical
i have a very difficult position for
david
so i suppose he will take this one
queen six
and uh hard to see what uh what he
should do here
uh he will not take the bishop on j6 no
i think he will try to keep the knight
enough sex was uh with some move
he's every so often he just glances
across this clock there obviously that's
uh
a big
extra strain
not just the position but the time
anxious moments yeah not easy
for david
yeah a nice mover knight takes h6 check
and we have to say it's looking
very promising for
alireza especially with board 2 looking
like a draw
so if alireza wins this one then i think
tomorrow it's uh enough for him to make
a draw right if he wins
he'll have seven and a half points
out of 10
and he'll be back in front again
i really i don't know what to do after
bishop g6
difficult position for black
yeah very difficult
indeed and
yeah
all white species are there
attacking and uh
and also one mistake from david he can
just become
quickly just become hopeless
i mean he might have a path to
save the game we're not sure um milan
over two of an interview
thank you very much we're joined by
vincent kmart who just won his game
against carol alexenko congratulations
on you
uh along the way you told me it was a
smooth witcher it doesn't happen that
easy usually could you just take us
through the key moments of the game
yeah okay i mean he played this rugged
in line which we also had played already
once in beale the same opening and yeah
back then he it was surprised to me and
okay for this game i prepared this line
and i think he surprised me with his
move h6 but it's always this kind of
position that black usually needs to
find a way to yeah get his counter play
pretty fast and i think probably in the
game he mixed up a move order or forgot
about an engine line and then it was
a really uncomfortable position i mean i
have basically very clear moves i can
have a very clear plan just play the
right moves and he has to somehow create
something and what he tried was okay
like of course risky but i mean if it
would have worked it was would have been
maybe not that bad anymore so it was a
good try i think but yeah i mean there
was just some concrete problems on the
king's side
you're now on six and a half points and
you're obviously in contention for the
top places now uh before the next round
uh how do you feel about the tournament
so far how's it been going for you
yeah i mean it has been going great for
me i mean i already won the second game
so i've been on plus one which would
already be great for me and then okay i
lost one game
immediately the first game after the
rest day against grand elias and now
having won three in a row i'm of course
really happy
uh just a more general note just let me
ask you what are your expectations on
the match in dubai between uh
ian nepomnichi and carlson
okay i certainly expect a tough match
because i mean it's known that nipples
always like at least has a head has had
a pretty good score against magnus and
also i think he's
yeah i mean his nerves are pretty good
so i think okay
who is the better player we will see but
i think also in a match it's always
about okay also preparation and yeah
feeling good being in good shape and
also having yeah the right mindset all
this stuff do you have a personal
favorite
absolutely not necessarily well just
okay
thank you well thank you very much and
good luck feel good thank you
yes milan thank you very much and
vincent cameron with a great victory
today over kyrie alexinko
we didn't check him we chucked it in the
beginning but then we uh maybe let's
take a look at this because uh i know
bishop just three yeah actually i
thought about the small maybe david
bishop takes g3
and
now i think
bishop f6 should we play
because if white starts with he swapped
on e8 under there looks like to me
actually yeah
we played quite fast so david uh
as we said already is short on time rook
takes the a check
okay i just wanted to say that uh maybe
like uh i don't know with which more
order may be first taken
on a g6 but uh i mean somehow yeah first
taking on g6 and then somehow to get
into this position where white is
forced to i know what this is even
though this is even
so after rookie two
maybe bishop f6 first
maybe even bishop f7 and uh queen e2 and
the king is
quite
with rook f1 to follow yeah
is coming
but he's taken on the edge with check
now how does that change things rook
takes a check has been played
yeah now after erg e8 uh after is just
three after hd6 uh so now could be six
check no longer wins the piece yeah he
has this bishop d4 so maybe that's the
point
and black's king is exposed of course
yeah this should be a winner i think
very uncomfortable for black ops color
bishops
with
a big attack coming black's way
and if 98 there's a checkmate here
somewhere after bishop f7
or queen h5
it uh it looks very dangerous indeed
doesn't it
david with three minutes now on his
clock and anna how many moves have they
made
uh 30
still 10 moves to reach the time control
the first time control
and
he hasn't recaptured 98 yet
yeah there is a joke that as uh vincent
won
german fence wants to want to stop the
count because
right now vincent joined the leaders
but the leaders are still playing police
are still playing yes
and
really david on the intense pressure
here
he hasn't recaptured yet on the eights
okay 98 is just uh yeah i don't believe
in 98
i think rookie 8 will be played
bishop eight it's more like he's played
with c8 natural move getting the rook uh
into the game
and a simple solution now is just f
takes
g3
for whites
there may be other ways to play i don't
know
is he going to surprise us again alireza
but um
simply pawn takes bishop f takes j3 f
takes g6
we assume
and then bishop takes f6
a pawn up and a very nice position for
white yeah i think black's chances to
save this one are quite low
also it's two minutes on the clock this
is also yeah of course
maybe we can check winston's game
because he said that it was quite an
easy win for him
just quickly take a look at the game
very quickly all right because uh
oh okay it was not a long game so uh we
saw this
one we did see the start didn't we
a little bit
so take stakes b5
bishop d3
at 94.
if
black
isn't on time to move the knight and
push c5 then of course the white's
position is
just with a pleasant edge so 97 ig3
knight e7 preparing c5
and now before stops yeah sure all this
contact is very nice for wait
f5 i think this is a mistake
it looks wrong to
to play to play this way within knights
on like no
piece like all the pieces on the
background and on the seventh round and
to push five uh i think it was
made by e4
at some moment
uh rookie one preparing e4
95 bishop d6 and 94 on the board
simply looks good for white six
bishop page six and after rook is three
ah we have six we have a draw
right
so the players are discussing
some lines
sure
okay well fabiano will be uh
we think perfectly
satisfied with that
might seem lesser
yeah this draw puts maxim in a must-win
situation for tomorrow that's right
and even then depending on the results
it may not be enough
okay
um so that game is over
uh we also have uh
virtugov against oparin still going with
things happening there we think and
alexis sheriff
against you young e so we'll have a very
quick look at these games and also david
hall of course on top board yeah this is
nikita's game against gregory so
queen g4 was played rook g8 now d7 what
you proposed
right knight is three
arrogant
this is the current position that's
where they are okay
well black seems
to be um
doing well
this pawn on design is of course very
dangerous if there were the kin was not
on b7 we could have error d7 idea yeah
rook d7 queen a1 checkmate
but of course still lawyer it's uh
what is struggling to
what will be struggling to make a draw
in this game
how is alexis shiro doing anna against
yuyani
here we have alexis shiro
down to four minutes for quite many
moves still 11 moves to make
but his position looks looks quite nice
he has a bishop
this bishop on h3 is a bit
out of place 61 check is just
been played and um
[Music]
something's happening in the
ali racing game against david howell as
well
uh so we should maybe have a very quick
look at david's just played a move in
fact something very co he played he
didn't play what we thought he was he
didn't take
so after rookie hit he didn't take he
played quinto f3
wow and look at david's reply
played on the intense time pressure as
well queen c6 goodness me
well and if rook takes queen that's made
him one rookie one mate
thank you and if not uh white has to
lose the temper from the rook yeah
that's the kind of move that you can
simply miss queen c6
easily miss
he played quickly didn't he uh
queen f3
yeah he probably missed this he played
queen of three after
two minutes well
but what's what is his idea now if the
rook moves somewhere bishop e5
comes and black is a piss up
wow
how's this game turned around
queen c6 from david howe with 30 or so
seconds on his club no i mean stewart
we got some help and
do you know which is the only move to
hold the balance now
well you'll have to tell me i don't know
bishop to situ
bishop c2 how does that
no that works uh i think that
no i don't understand and if queen takes
c2
queen takes g3 check or something like
that
yeah
and if bishop moves somewhere
okay if we should move to if bishop
moves to e5 there is idea to take and
the bishop h7
still even but you know he didn't have
to play queen afriana he could have just
played ftx g3 with we thought with the
safe first example
otherwise you will never play it
so after queen g3 there is rook g5 and
after bishop to h7
i think knight h7 takes takes
and i prefer black's position hmm
well i didn't know about that maybe if
black just consolidate all the pieces
it's uh it's even winning
i don't see how this bishop c2 helps
bishop e5
so
instead of just just show us again where
he played queen f3 honor the position
where white played queen f3
where was where the queen the queen was
on d1
the queen was here and he had a very
simple move you could have played leftix
g3 we anticipated after xg3 after extra
six bishop takes f6
with uh well and i thought it was
quite big advantage for white in this
position because the king is too much
exposed
with the queens on the board if of
course black
manages to try the queens then the
chances to to hold the game are high
very high but with the queens on the
border the position is quite unpleasant
goodness me
yeah and look at le reza he completely
amazed going to c6
and you know sometimes it's what uh i
think you said the other day about being
short of time sometimes when one is
shorter time as david
usually is
uh in fact your opponent
tries to
win
push you over the edge you know just by
playing fast uh themselves as well and
then you can make mistakes and it looks
like alireza here has done precisely
that
and um he's completely missed this
well pretty amazing move from david
queen b7 to c6 yeah a bit surprising
because it's known to be a good tactical
player
but yeah maybe he started to play to
play on time to play on time yeah and um
now um well who knows
queen c6 now another question how to
hold this balance after bishop system
bishop c2 is that really uh the only
move with
i mean uh why two piece down
rook is attacked
on c1 he cannot play rook takes c6
because he's check mate rookie one is
checkmate
if white moves the rook
for example rook d1 then black can play
bishop e5 he's a whole piece up
so um
just show us and if rook takes queen
just here's the checkmate so everyone
can follow you want to see the
checkmaster well i want to see it i mean
i think people would like to see it yeah
this is the problem that is checkmate
so the queen cannot be taken
meanwhile the rook on c1 is attacked
okay if any other move yeah if d1 f1 or
wherever and then bishop e5
right
so the queen on c6 is doing another
important job protecting the
knight on f6 exactly
so let's take a look at this only more i
try to find the solution after bishop e5
so black prepared to give his queen up
and we looked at that
bishop six e5 and bishop h7 check
yeah i think white has to take then
bishop h7 knight h7
takes takes takes and something like
this
and well
i wouldn't be sure how to evaluate this
i mean i see black as a past deep one
but
maybe there is some perpetual queen g3
versus rook g5 maybe queen c3 or e6
queen g3
okay
i don't know
check
but
g6 queen b8
or if queen g3 check rook g5 and then
the rook can come back to g6 to defend
the bishop there's this check
knight f8
but now white has to fight further yeah
goodness me
a complete
well let's not say turn around but um
plot twist
yeah you can say that um wow
and look uh the clock times david
with something like 34 seconds on his
clock
we think
um yeah another dresser just made a
mistake he just missed his queen c6 move
yeah big blunt he had a safe edge
pawn up with a good position
he tried to play trick-or-treating he
tried this sort of to win
uh
in a sharper
quicker fashion
and it has just backfired completely
after this queen c6 myth
and david will uh
will be very aware that he now has a
chance not just to save this game but
possibly even to put a bit of pressure
on
good news for you good
for the english man
[Music]
well a real uh
real turnaround and as you say a plot
twist
there is a draw in the game between sam
seville and uh
some seven jewelry all right
sam seven drew against uh gabrielle
sarguson
okay so that means both of these players
will be
on six and a half out of ten
all right fine
so um yeah let's go back to the actual
position and right
yeah once again the engines say
uh the engines say that bishop c2 is the
only move in this position the only move
is to
not have a lost position
yeah otherwise we should be five and
like super soap and black space up
goodness me
queen c6 well david had to find that
move and he found it with
he played it was four seconds on the
clock with four seconds he played well
that's right he's got 34 seconds
and uh
yeah yeah it feels like colorado is
becoming nervous
yeah i mean having a comfortable
position pressing uh
and then finding this knight h6 idea yes
which was a great move and suddenly
after a queen of three queens of six he
has to fight for a draw
and knowing
of course that he could have played f
takes g3 yeah yeah it's psychological
had a safe
position
with every chance of converting as well
and also uncomfortable for back to play
wasn't it
shorter time
also the next moves will come quickly
if you go into the into this fourth line
and uh david will have we'll come along
sometime that's right
that's right
so really bishop c2 we believe is the
right move here
but black may have an advantage
if he doesn't play bishop c2 anna
um it's
it's just a piece down i'm really quite
dubious for it
and so taking a big risk as well because
if david gets to the time control and
he's a piece up
it might just be uh just be winning
white just has one pawn for his piece at
the moment
a very uncomfortable situation for
larissa right yeah we can see he missed
it yeah
he unfortunately made this quest
brilliant move there from david howe
queen b7 to c6
now he's i feel like he's both angry
sad
very frustrating as well i'm sure
for him
to have made that one slip and what was
a really nice game as well
up to that point
just a little bit careless and really
provoked in part i think by david's time
shortage the fact that david had so
little time
i think was a factor in um
ali reza playing queen f3 too quickly
i remember that when i was young uh
there was even a recommendation like
what did he do he's played bishop c2 i
believe i explained bishop city
going
uh yeah i just yeah when i was young i
mean when i was a kid there was even a
recommendation if you have a really bad
position go into the time trouble
because then your opponent may start
playing uh like just on your time and
miss something does david play bishop v8
there i don't know after bishop c2 after
bishop c2 yeah we should be eight he's
played bishop b8
bishop b8
we thought bishop e5 didn't we
sacrificing and prepared to sacrifice
the queen
is the only move we looked at we should
be five
bishop b8
what is happening if coin f6
if uh if queen takes f6 then
more black's just going into an end game
right takes takes roxy 8 or
something that is a surprise bishop b8
what a game huh for top board
i think bishop hate is uh
not that big surprise i mean compared
but bishop c2 was found so he managed to
he found bishop c2 possibly um
we think the only move
we expected we should be five he's
played bishop b8
so if bishop takes f6 then uh queen
takes c2 still works
right there is checkmate a checkmate
again on the back
so in fact black threatens here queen
takes c2 that is black threat queen six
bishop yeah of course like bishop f6
then uh then we just take on c2 and we
say we win the game
so queen f6 or uh
or what else or what else
i think nothing black has to take
otherwise it's checkmate black must take
take take and now there are options
right
black
but bishop c3 seems to
seems to be okay
does
this d4 work or not really
looks like he's played
he's been in exchange on f6 twice yeah
he's taken on f6
and he's played rook c8 exactly
but is this position better than the one
we discussed after bishop e5 i mean for
black
bishop c3 all as we
were saying anna this position now on
the board
here he is a pawn down
so maybe
i don't know
bishop if i looked like a better option
is there a tactic for black here or not
which one um
bishop
bishop d6 or something to take on a3 or
bishop the second just bishop d3 i think
maybe d4 bishop d4 bishop f4
d4 bishop takes bishop f4 bishop e3 not
working no takes takes bishop five
bishop f4 then after this we have bishop
f5 when's the piece the line we
we were talking about but bishop d2
right
exactly bishop d2
what is wrong with that
nothing huh
bishop d2 and
okay white is upon up sure it's a bit
surprising that david played bishop b8
once again
he's gonna have to make a move he's
played d4
okay
which move number is that on it d4
35 35 okay he's got 30 seconds
so bishop no
bishop d2 we think
bishop d2 how is he going to save this
one bishop e5
should be five bishop this ring he's
played bishop d2 yeah
that's right bishop d2 is probably the
only move
and next move as you say bishop d3 and
blocks the pawn
and white is what
has a safe extra pawn we think
yeah we should be five it's not possible
due to
bishop h7
this bishop v8 move was maybe uh not not
the right one anna
when he had that bishop e5
option
okay
like to play inside 30 seconds
let's move this king
to g7
i mean there was a problem bishop b5 for
example simply lost a bishop h7 check
so he's moved his king
but after bishop d3
and um yeah i think he has to take
it's a pawn up isn't it
simply pawn up
i think it should be winning
four bishop ending
after king of six we have g4
which provides bishop to stop by right
also king of system might take on h6 or
not
i thought about i mean i thought about
uh giving the spawn but to
change yeah this idea was pushed
to push the pawn
maybe bishop a6 is also possible but g4
also i can bring his king to e2
yeah we're unpleasant
so um
yeah
another plot twist
after the earlier one everything looks
so bad then oh queen c6
now we're back and then bishop oh now
everything looks so bad again
well it's easy for us to say uh what's
the point moves out here um
yeah without any pressure yeah without
any pressure but when you're sitting
there
on top board after 10 uh nine rounds
already
and you're playing for
for the canyons for the candidates then
uh you know
to choose between bishop e5 or bishop
esp8 or something is
yeah i agree not at all straightforward
um the other line meant giving
up his queen of course
so they're still not at mu 40.
um just remind us how many moves do they
have to go
uh king j7 number 36 so four to go
four moves to go
and ali rays are down to about five
minutes
just to
remind us all of the time control that
after they reach the first time control
move 40 they will each have 50 minutes
for the next 20 moves
and then if the game is still in
progress another 15 minutes those are
the results on us so far
and we had an interview with vincent
there very uh impressive victory over
kiro alexenko
yeah sure and also three draws but also
many games in progress
uh there is another result
in the game uh levon arunian won his
game against another background there we
see the women's resort sana sorry
uh latency winning a drawing and winning
the tournament there and the win for
daisy cody against nana so we'll maybe
come back and have a look at that
but first um let's keep up to date he's
a corey amazing girl yeah
another one for her
yeah also julia osmak
beat
alina kashlinska actually alina suffered
two defeats in a row yeah
so um what has happened to h5 we see
from david
uh bishop destroyer has been played
error takes rook takes and h5 so maybe
he's preparing to play king
and prevents g4 from uh from white as
well
but now what is some time to put the kin
on it
the skin of one and can you turn
that's right
um certainly could play that
i wonder if bishop g5 would be make
sense and after f6 just come back with
the bishop to d2
i think that makes a lot of sense
actually
yeah bishop g5
bishop g5
good move
after f6 uh
bishop d2
still some moves to go before they reach
the control
okay let's try to keep all the bishops
on the board because if uh if you have a
bishop straight
doesn't matter light squares or
a black
or dark square bishop then
white's task will be much easier
yeah white has a three against two
majority on the king side and the
black's deep one is
blocked
so white will try to bring the kin to e2
and then think about
pushing b3 i don't know bishop c4 and b3
or bishop c2 and b3 and make a press
pawn over there yeah
if bishop saturday always bishop b5 so
maybe bishop c4 and b3
so um
difficult times ahead for david here
are you one more update baby sarah
survivor won her game oh well she just
won and she got her
gm congratulations congratulations to
her she beat chevalier was it that she
was playing today
what a fantastic performance from
bibisara
alireza has played a move meanwhile
let's see what he played after david's
h5
seems like he played h4
h4 all right
not the uh so maybe he wants to play
bishop g5 after king f6
king of six bishop g5 check
all
right then king could come to e5 maybe
still a couple of moves that david has
to play here
to get to the control of move 40
he can still play
like king f6 bishop g5 maybe simply king
f1 king e2 on earth king of 6.
then why did he
hard with h4 or he was
maybe he didn't want to allow h4 from
black yeah
if it's done something else
see what he's played bishop c6 maybe
bishop c6
okay
thinking f1
f1 g3
right um
or we shouldn't hire with g3
no maybe you can play just for a king f1
then g3 if bishop f3 you play bishop to
bishop e2
right
maybe he wanted to fix that h5 pawn
there on on that square
but clearly white is a safe pawn up up
and um
must be uh good winning chances for
aliexa
after that scare that queen c6 scare
and um
a very wild
complications
which may have been in black's favor
possibly
another draw on board aid between sana
seguro and pantala krishna
okay
so what's he going to play king f1 yeah
kind of
fun i am voting for kineform
simply bringing his king out and then
he'll have to play um
probably g3 to free the king from the
defense of the chutu pawn
again bishop g5 anna is a possibility
here you could play the move i said
before bishop g5
and he'll also start with g3 perhaps
maybe it's more or less the same
yes he's played g3 look
so uh alireza reached move 40 and he
stood up right
and
david still has to make one move
[Music]
one last move and get 50 minutes
right
i think he's the only player who
mentioned that he likes this long time
control
yeah
he does like it um
he's gone back with his bishop he looks
like a bishop to this side he didn't
look very happy with himself there did
he
so just sorry bishop g7 okay
they reached more 40 and
right okay
and um
i think and we may be having a quick
break now
and then uh we'll be back with uh all
the action from the women's event as
well as of course
as um this game and the others from the
open section so we'll see you all in a
couple of minutes
[Music]
do
want to hold a massive chess tournament
with dozens of clubs or hundreds of
players or maybe a small chess
tournament with local but competitive
clubs with club arenas you can
club arenas allow for tournaments of any
size with any number of clubs and
players customize the arena with any
time control with standard chess or mini
chest variants and with any starting
position you want club arenas are the
most flexible tournament format on
chess.com try one out today
and welcome back everyone i am anna
mazuchuk here with stuart conquest and
we are commentating on around 10. this
time it's wrong
not around 8. it's around 10. and still
many games many exciting games are in
progress a couple of games have been
finished on the top board both in open
and women's section but
this game between lara zafa and david
hall crazy game absolutely absolutely
crazy game with ups and downs and it's
still on progress the players reached
move 40 so they got additional 50
minutes on the clock and now david is
happy to have time for to think again
that's right the last move was king g1
to f1 from alireza
so what can we say another white
basically it's a pawn up for
for nothing it's an extra white pawn
and david has a real
task
ahead to try to save this position
the only problem about white's position
is that
these two pawns are blocked by this pawn
on a4 so white has to solve this task by
trying to push b3 or before
but first it's good to bring the kin to
closer to towards the center so can f1
can need two and then think about
uh
about how to push b3 here we have the
results in the women's section and uh a
fine win there for bibisara
from kazakhstan anna who makes
the grand master norm
congratulations to bibi sarah
on this win and of course for
getting the gm norm
uh also daisy corey another win
amazing girl she lost her first three
then she won five in the first three
games then winning five making a draw
yesterday and winning one more game so
she's six and a half out of
uh 10 and also another win by julia
ozmak against um those are the open
results and just the single decisive
results so far which is uh vincent kemah
who beats kiril alexenko so
congratulations to him and the other
games uh the without uh resorts is
obviously still going on but the others
have been drawn
so we have games to check up on as well
but um that's david howell on the screen
by the way apparently bibi sarah didn't
know that she'd made a groundmaster norm
she was a bit surprised
how sweet is that
but sometimes it's good sometimes it's
because you just come to play the game
without this pressure like how many
points do i need if i win will it be
enough or
or not
so
just play a tournament and then if you
make it if you make it you make it what
if it's your first gm norm maybe
i to be honest i don't know but maybe it
may be her first one
but anyway big congratulations to her
she's um
played a really good tournament and of
course playing for a good price money
tomorrow as well
yeah i think she's like gaining maybe
around 30 points in this tournament
a wonderful performance by bb sarah and
yeah one more game tomorrow so she will
try to fight for for the prizes uh
nobody can fight for the candidate sport
in the women's section anymore that's
right so ladies already the winner of
the tournament
but
yeah
there are still many prizes and
there are
do we see david's made a move okay why
did he play
um i'm not sure he looked like bishop b5
should be five
yeah how did you see it behind the board
bishop p8 e5 and um
well
difficult to know what to suggest for
black i mean uh talking about porn
islands anna as we have a couple of
times here black has four of them
four porn islands so um white has two
so um
four potentially weak pawns here
okay i'll try to suggest something here
after kidney 2 maybe we can check
and after three move the bishop back and
the pawn on g3 will begin
and if king d2 if kindy two
i don't know because so yeah it covers
the bishop but it starts
threatening bishop to b5 so
that's right we should be fire as a
threat here isn't it
uh maybe let's check vittigo's game yes
let's look at the other kinds of
questions
goodness me look at this
have they reached the time control
yeah they did they did read the time
control
and um this has also been a thrilling
game where um
there was that amazing knight d4 move
and then other adventures as well
but it looks like black is
doing great here maybe winning simply
okay queen f1 is a simple threat
[Music]
but i don't see i don't see how white
can save this one if rook moves
somewhere let's say rookie one even the
queen d4 wins
exactly that's right
simply quinn default win then yeah
nikita vitsukov here russian champion
but um
[Music]
quite an upset here if he loses this
which it looks like he's going to yeah
with white pieces it's quite painful
i mean he obviously tried to win today
he took chances he played uh
some uh
moves which
he may not have done if the situation
has been different
and gregorio pouring if he wins this one
he will be
he'll have seven points out of ten
that's right four
um now what about alex's shadow house
heating against you yangi
there we see alexey
and somehow black's got this
far advanced past e pawn
looks very good for black it does
it does look very good for black
i thought about some g45 idea but after
g4 there is e2 and then queen e3 comes
taking the spawn
it does look uh very dangerous isn't it
so
something unpleasant anyway
yeah alexa played a very interesting
game i really liked his opening choice
and then how he played
um
at this move a4 a wonderful move right
but it looks like uh
something went wrong in the time trouble
now he is fighting for a draw
so um pierre
he's had a really magnificent tournament
uh alexa this far but
yeah both players on six out of nine
now the let's say undefeated up to today
but here this might be a big test of
that
clearly you young pushing to win
and what about andreas panko we should
be fire bishop too
yes what happened
they're still playing
they're still playing now white is a
pawn up
i think he's close to win this game just
uh rook d2 or d5
save pawn up
or uh rook a2 and uh rugby five and just
push the pawn
apparently anna this this game had to be
uh they had to move
uh because the over
the overhead lighting the light that was
uh focused on this game
uh stopped working or something like
that and they had to move to a different
board earlier in the game
i didn't know about that yeah so
just one of those things that
occasionally happens
obviously if the lighting is not right
then
then the game yeah then we don't play
without slides
so the arbiters would have stepped in
and taken that decision
yeah sometimes it happens that the light
disappears you see that's where they
were playing i believe you see
and now where are they now there's
somewhere else yeah actually true
because there was some problem we had
then you had some other moves in this
game then we were back to this game so
maybe
um maybe the organizers tried to
make it technical doesn't look too bad
the other lighting does it but maybe uh
it's it's not what it is no the lighting
is actually very good
uh but yeah maybe something happened to
the light just over them right
but anyway um the game is still
in progress that's the position and
yesterday
is playing there with an extra prawn for
white
and certainly has very healthy winning
chances let's say
yeah just yeah i think rook a2 would be
it's a good plan
to improve the position
black and also try to bring the kin to
g3
some
there's alireza on
camera
and um
which move does he play donna
king has come across uh sorry this is
maxim's game
he played
looks like he played bishop e2
he's brought his king across to d2
hasn't he or not
yeah
kenny too bishop g4 and kindly too
right david also made a move
bishop designed back
yeah okay because bishop b5 as we said i
think was a threat and if blackwood
lives at a4 pawn that would really be
the end of the end of the game so he's
gone back to d7
okay and what about the second part of
the plan bishop c4 and b3 right
david uh sort of with his head in his
hands and
maybe thinking about
the position
before the time control
after queen c6 and
maybe that bishop v8 move and i was uh i
was advised not to think about such
things and during the game
not to think about what's gone before
but just to yeah because you can't take
it back so what's the point right well
yeah
so um if outer racer can win this
position pawn up
against david howell he then goes back
into seoul lead of this event
but still he would have to at least get
a draw tomorrow wouldn't he
to sort of guarantee
the canada's place i think
he might actually play a part in our yu
yang gear tomorrow
bishop's not on c4 yet he hasn't played
that bishop d7 the last move
right to play
he's about to make a move king c2 and i
think he mentions that
okay he wants to keep the bishop on d3
also opening his dark square bishop
the thing is the black has no counter
play of course and uh
and if black plays bishop e6 then i
think b should be five bishop bishop
d3 and then somehow
to give this default pawn
and we have the result gregorio parent
seems to win
right against nikita
if you want his game against the guitar
that's a big result
uh 7 out of 10 for gregorio pine
right
he's having a really great event he
hasn't lost any games i don't think
yeah bitcoin today
and um
and now he is one of the candidates
yeah
he will try to fight tomorrow he will
play with white pieces very likely
so he has chances
he could play alireza perhaps sir
we saw maxine drew with fabiano
earlier
okay if he wins and you young yi i mean
uh he already won but if yuyan gee also
wins then i think you and g has better
chances to play against uh aloreza
because
by the pairings it's like the higher
rated player
so um no maybe it's too early to predict
something
i mean alexis sheriff may uh
may be able to defend that position we
don't know there's alexi
born and bred here in riga
uh yeah what about alexa's game
he hasn't made any moves or
or there are no objects
in fact
looks like he's just played a move
bishop to d4
bishop
b2 to d4
okay
what about queen e4 uh are we going to
play bishop b6 i was thinking about that
just now yes
quentin queen e4 bishop looks dangerous
but maybe it works
this is just bishop b6
and then if e2 of course queen e1
i'll actually looking at this score
sheet though
bishop d4 looks like a good move because
otherwise e2 and queen s3 was coming
right he's taking the e3 square from
black screen correct
and yeah there may be a counter play
with bishop b6 against black's
a5 pawn
in some lines
what about queen e6
queen e6 maybe queen e1 to 4c2 anyway
and then just try to defend this
position
after all it's nothing
nothing down i mean uh
yeah but this uh eater pawn
it's yeah
it's very dominating it
white could play bishop f2 maybe
uh imagineer
well he may yet save this
maybe
try to create another weakness yeah if
one is not enough for some h5
uh okay here we have an upcoming
interview with uh
gregorio parents so milan all too thank
you very much anna yes grigorio pardon
is joining us now who just won a game
against nikita with hugo congratulations
on your victory thank you
it was a crazy game you said it yourself
earlier could you just uh take us
through it for the key moments
yeah indeed it was a crazy game nikita
went for a very strategically risky
opening with white and then he had to
destabilize the position
he went for this 94 piece sacrifice
which i did not accept and i think that
was the right decision i just wanted to
keep my structures so solid and just
do not
give him any counterplay
and well i felt that i had advantage
from that point on
to be honest it wasn't easy but
it just my pawn structure is so much
superior than his that
i felt that in the end
i should just grab those points yes his
position just fell apart uh
i i've heard anna instead of commenting
at the beginning that a very interesting
move when you make king d7
instead of and then the king
gradually made his way to the queen side
uh could just elaborate more on that
yeah i mean it's a although it's a
typical idea to bring the king to c7 and
like king d7 is just a very nice-looking
move and
i mean for me it was the most logical
move because the point is that we don't
really want to try to move our queen on
d8 yet and i would responsiate yet
for example i could do basically the
same but just play queen e7 then bishop
d7 casts a wrong
but
it's not clear my bishop belongs for
example i can go to a6 as well
my queen won't get uh
under attack on d8 because there are
some ideas of knight g3 knight f5
so yeah king d7 seemed like a good way
and
i calculated to beat this f4 thing and i
didn't see it working for white so i
just went for it yeah
so you're now on seven out of ten uh
it's been generally how would you assess
the tournament so far for you how's it
been
yeah it's going amazing obviously
i mean
uh i got to lucky in some games but
that sport yeah
so today i think i want a pretty high
quality game so i'm happy about today's
game
and yeah
i'm just playing game of the game
yes you mentioned earlier that these
last rounds make people feel a bit
nervous
so does this
does this does that tension is it felt
in the air
here when you enter the playing hall
yeah i mean you can feel it on all the
boards like
people cannot uh
just win winning positions or bronzer
and then move the dirt right so
so okay so
for tomorrow obviously you still know
who you will be playing but you're now
with with 7 out of 10 you're clearly in
the race
uh
will you be
preparing in a special way other than
than you normally do or is it going to
be like any other game
well probably i'll just do the same
where we see i mean
first we need to see the pairings and
then yeah and then you'll know okay
thank you very much and good luck with
tomorrow thank you thank you so much
yes thank you milan and thank you
gregory congratulations to him
um for that very exciting
victory over nikita vithugov we enjoyed
that game didn't we yeah it was a very
interesting game with kinder sung it's a
17-7 manual were also
knight d4 move from nikita uh vitigo was
quite spectacular
uh but
then as gregory mentioned uh
nikita played in a very risky
uh way and uh his strategy uh didn't
work so that's right that's right well i
mean nikita was clearly trying to win
today with wyatt and chose a
double-edged
strategic line and um played very
sharply and
it sort of didn't quite work out from
today did it
so um
okay this is uh the top board game we
see arireza there on camera against
david hall he's a clear pawn up
and anna what's the the latest moves
here
knc2 bishop e6 this is the current
position right and it feels like alert
is very close to win this one
i agree yeah bishop b5 uh bishop b3
king d3
and then
bring the bishop round to take on d4
oh let's say king f6
but after bishop d2 can sex
we may think about bishop c4
yes
that's right here
um
is it so clear if we take an d3
okay and the bishop c3 d2
uh maybe still
bishop b4
when the king moves to d5 we play bishop
e8
okay bishop c5 is a threat
well but then black
so um if blackwood awaits here bishop
well how does he wait
f6
maybe i'll be it
yeah then bishop b8 hits h5 that's
another problem
that's another problem you can't really
do that it's like black is a pawn down
but also
all these three exactly
that's right are quite
weak
four weaknesses really
you could say that
and black has to keep them all he's a
pawn down already he can't afford to
lose another pawn
so um
every chance of ali raiser winning but
uh we of course we're going to keep
following the game
and um
we'll see uh what happens we're going to
have a very short break
maybe we keep the camera on that game
because it's
board number one and it's the most
important game for today so
we are just going for a short break and
we will be back shortly we'll see you in
a couple of minutes
[Music]
the new chess.com events page has
arrived
find all the games from top tournaments
around the world as well as
championships played right here on
chess.com
explore each game and even vote on who
you think will win their matchups
review standings schedules key
information and find links to all the
top news surrounding each event
head to chess.com events today and
experience your favorite tournaments
like never before
yes and welcome back everyone and here
we are in riga latvia day 10 round 10 of
the feedahs.com grand swiss and women's
grand swiss and uh lots of drama and
excitement today as every day
and we've been following um the top
games of course those are the women's
results anna and we have a winner
leitinji yeah led india the winner of uh
swiss 2021 congratulations to latin gm
uh but also we have an important
uh result on board number three zuzener
won the game and she scored a gm norm
brilliant
congratulations to zhu zhendra uh we
have to say that earlier
actually before that round she also
scored um gm norm and bibisara survival
by winning against paulina chavalla
another gm norm so three
in the women's event
well done to all three players of course
these are the current results in the
open event so many draws uh an important
win for grigore oparin with black
against nikita virtugov he gave us an
interview a short time ago and also
vincent kama winning uh convincingly
against killer alexenko the other games
so far have ended in draws
this is the top board game
you're going to say bishop b5 bishop b3
and king destroyer was played okay
david howell here um playing
black of course a pawn down and um
there was a very exciting moment in this
game wasn't anna with queen c6 in
david's time trouble which he found with
uh well less than 30 seconds on his
clock and it looked like the game almost
turned around
didn't it it was very unclear but then
the next move i think bishop 8 was a
mistake
so um
high drama in this game but now uh ali
is a safe healthy pawn to the good david
howell has
four
let's call them isolated pawns anyway he
has to keep them all defended and white
has a plan of trying to round up this
pawn on d4
maybe king f6
black could play try to bring his king
towards
d5
but very tough to haul donna what do you
think yeah we spoke about king of six
and all the ideas which might happen in
this game
additionally you know late in chief
she's the winner of the event but uh is
now at uh clear second with seven points
out of ten right so it's and they play
each other tomorrow and they play
chelsea it's automatically yeah they
haven't faced each other so they have to
play against each other
uh so two chinese players in the
tournament and being on the very top
yeah dominating chinese dominance of
this event and well they're both both
both ladies have played really well
and as we just had a gm nom for
zuchinner today um having beaten laila
javikish philly so david's made a move
akin to g6
king g6 not king f6 and what is the
difference if you still play
bishop d2
right
bishop t2 the plan is to play bishop b4
or bishop a5 and then come to c5
or b6 and just take this deep one
alire's on our screens
now he looks confident yeah when he
missed queen c6 right he didn't look so
confident absolutely he didn't yeah
he clearly missed queen c6 he played
that queen f3 move didn't he
he had a safe alternative he could have
been a pawn up with a
with a nice uh safe edge he chose a
sharp move instead in david's time
travel and was hit by queen c6
and
all of a sudden the game was
wide open again and maybe david had a
chance on the following move as well
maybe let's check alexa's game
as it's also a very important game of
today's round
alexis show so he has brought his speech
back to f2
so e2 was played queen e1 queen e4 and
bishop f2
not a pleasant position for alexey but
still he's playing he's fighting
that's right
and
[Music]
i have the idea to bring the skin to
like to
h f3 or somewhere
sure
do you think white could try to play c4
c2 to c4
try to free his position a bit
is that his idea
i don't know what to say because it may
appear to be
good it can be also bad
as it's working in the king
i even had another idea to bring the
bishop to f5 or to g4
yes
yeah you could start he couldn't you
could play bishop c8 here in fact
bishop c8 and if king d2 bishop comes to
g4
not at all pleasant for whites
yeah i'm
quite passive
i still prefer kinfsa in this position
just to wait to see what white is going
to do but maybe your idea was c4 is
right
well imagine c4 or c3 yeah after c3 of
course c4 maybe
maybe queen d3
yeah this is a really tremendous pawn on
e2 isn't it
yeah
another genius player
i was about to say with two the two
chinese women doing so well
in the women's section and um
yang yi here if he wins
he also moves to seven points hannah
with options for picking up one of those
two
candidate spots
as well
so right now we have fabiana corona and
gregorio parent was seven points seven
out of ten
right
and if alireza wins he will be on seven
and a half that's right
and his andradean andres panko
ah he did play he did play rook a2 he
pushed the pawn to a5
and oh yeah it's quite close to winning
yeah he's playing here krish
krishnan sassy killen from india who's
had a very good solomon indeed
but it looks like um this may not be
going his way
clear pawn up for white
by the way alexandre gorache i think she
had a good result today anna
oh yeah she won her first game so
finally
who did she play
i think she played in nations if i'm not
mistaken
i'll check have a quick look
yeah
nations uh look well latvian grandmaster
so um congratulations to her the only
female in the open
section
so now she's on minus one yeah
i'm not sure
um which is how many points she's on
david they're looking wow
not looking too happy is he
minus two
yeah he's in a very difficult position
uh we can understand him
our bishop d7 played
okay preventing uh
white could also play bishop d7 after
king f5
but okay yes he could have waited
is he threatening also move like bishop
f4
could be
because immediately bishop f4 i think
black could take and play king f5 and
maybe it's still losing but it's already
some kind of counter play sure no need
to allow that that's right no no but uh
now black's king is not allowed to get
to the f5 square
so one idea maybe uh
bishop f4 thing is the white holds all
the asus here white can
set black problems on
across the whole board more or less and
uh
can often exchange your bishops can
attack black spawns
prevent black skin coming out
so very tough indeed for
for black
maybe let's check some other games which
are still in progress not on the top
boards all right maybe something
exciting is happening there
uh here we have yuri kozuba against nils
carondellos
i think this will be a draw
yep i think sushi
everyday artemia
who scored a victory yesterday and who
was really very happy about that because
he started with six draws or something
like that right
look at black's king there on d3 wow
uh super active king just kinda
and if white starts pushing exactly yeah
you think just b5 and just push maybe
94.
all right and if b6 just come back yeah
maybe black will hold this
hmm
can this rain
he wants to fall for his knight doesn't
he as well now
sorry he wants to put his knight on d4
uh or in the quincy took in b2
play for win
not really
david has played the move bishop d1
we should be three to d1 all right
now should white play bishop f4 or not
sometimes in such positions there is
even an idea to sacrifice was before
after all
to get across
bishop b2 and then just to move this
that's that's quite clever
yeah also once again there is no need in
this position but just like an idea
lots of um
[Music]
lots of things i could do just bring
again bring his bishop round bishop d2
bishop b4
bishop f4 is quite a concrete move isn't
it
maybe then king f6
just check
right you can check of course that's
true i've got to go back
be sure to
play the move
bishop d2 do you think
i think bishop to our play
it looks that way yeah bishop d2
yeah
i think it's what does black do black
just has to keep everything protected
and uh
but it's just impossible to to keep
everything proper
after king of sex bishop uh before all
already two is the threat because the
bishop can't
control both of these pawns
unfortunately i can't find any chances
for doubt
in the current position
yeah it's um
i think it's too much really to to ask
to um
to defend this one
weak pawns and a pawn less
white's king stands well on d3
and the white bishop is controlling
the squares really that they need to
so um well two years ago david uh
had chances didn't he going into the
last round in fact at the isle of man
in this event in the ground swiss and he
lost his last round
to wang if i'm not mistaken
oh yeah indeed
and here um
it looks like uh although he's won four
games in a row to get himself into this
position on top board equal first
going into the tenth round
it looks like uh
it's not going to happen for me is it
this time either
but anyway we'll stick we'll stay with
this game
any other results anna or any other um
games we could uh have a quick look at
alexis sheriff we've seen is in trouble
against uh
you young here okay we have let's say
cheryl andreas panko
on the top 10 boards
uh maybe let's check if there are any
updates in that games uh
so roxy is six and andre is still
thinking
okay
so what can he do maybe
i think black is preparing rook
a to c7
so maybe he can try uh a4
with the idea of rook b6 if i work to c7
then kin b3 and still uh
really checks after that white would
like to swap a pair of works i guess
yeah
then it will be easier to push the pawn
okay fourth with the other b6 i like
that myth
yeah
sure
and alexa's game
nothing happens yet nothing
what about top women's games
okay let's have a quick look i think the
first five boards already
offended their games so we have uh board
number six
but we are going to against innovation
this looks like
we haven't followed this game at all
have we but um no i don't remember
plug to play
it looks like uh
it might just be a draw
yeah if can you see two
check first check
and then put the rook behind the pawn
we have kind d2 or can be three first uh
rugby five and h5 yeah looks like it's
sacrifice and then draw
and the board number
10 antonetta stefano against roy charlie
so um
b5 before just played from vaishali
so it's either a white text on before
or rook d5 okay right it takes a group
takes back maybe
it was also possible to take on e4 maybe
it was easier to take on e4 takes takes
takes
right
okay also very close to a draw
or not
i think so yeah
okay back to the open section uh bishop
c8 all right you're right actually you
said bishop set to f5 maybe
it looks good yeah putting pressure on
c2 of course
very unpleasant for alexey
okay who else do you have ah this one
may be interesting prague and i guess
girlfriend
right one of the youngest participants
against one of them one of the oldest
that's right
uh two pieces in the pawn for a rook
but it's white to move where to play
boris gave a nice interview didn't he
yesterday on the on the broadcast he
didn't only gave a nice interview he
played a very interesting game with five
coins that's right actually that's
exactly right
and he won
so uh what do we think something here
anna
it's a bit unclear
i thought about rook e2
uh is it playable or it's just that
black takes on e8 and knight f8
and maybe you just lose the two or also
bishop somewhere bishop h4 or something
now
david how there we can see uh on
on our screens
i don't think he's played any moves no
he played move now f looks like a 5
on f7 f5
well he has to keep going i mean
[Music]
always a chance isn't there
always
the possibility that whites will
somehow um
not find the way through
maybe even f4
right
and then bishop before bishop a5 f1 then
bring the bishop round
bishop presumably has to stay defending
that
d4 pawn let's try bishop f6 on bishop g7
i rather took his jacket off
right
what does it mean
there there he
is just 18 years old
i think
and um
well he's very close to winning this
game and then he'll be
half a point ahead
a very important game for earl reza
absolutely well of course also for david
but uh alireza is really close to win
this one
so if he wins he of course has excellent
chances to to get one of the
that's right
oh one of two spots for the kenya's
tournament
okay
we uh maybe anna we should take a little
break just a short one and um
we will of course be right back uh to
pick up the action on the top board game
and the other games such as alexis
shiros
and andreas cepenko and so on the other
game still going on here live in riga
latvia so we'll see you very very soon
[Music]
welcome welcome everyone this is the
speeches championship finals going down
here with carlson and nakamura
the bullet portion comes to an end
hikaru nakamura
is mathematically eliminated in his
chances and the bottom line is magnus
carlsen shows why he is the magnus
carlsen
it has been hicaro's speeches
championship this 2018 and wesley so had
an amazing event this year as well and
we were tied heading into bullet before
akara nakamura separated himself in the
final portion
he blunders his rook and it's just
things are just not going well for
wesley they traded back and forth
landing heavy blows but ultimately the
heavyweight matchup is going to go
toward a karnakamore's favor
akara will be winning his third in a row
extremely impressive display once he
actually faced a deficit he has looked
like the best of carl we've seen
[Music]
and welcome back everyone here is the
live broadcast from riga latvia it's
around 10.
uh penultimate round in both events
there are still some games in progress
and of course uh
one board one two board still in
progress so we will definitely first
check this game
so that's right and there we see uh on
camera ali eraser ferucia
and he's just played bishop f4 anna
looks like
which we we kind of discussed
because we discussed f4 we had the idea
of bishop before a couple of months ago
but uh
he decided to play it after f5 was
played maybe
it's just like many moves are
winning this position
white is upon up and also uh
black has many other weaknesses like all
these pawns even now f5 pawn is
can be considered to be weak yes
it's a very difficult situation for
david howe well we don't actually
believe he'll manage to save this game
but it was a crazy game before
i mean for example if david were to
place king to f6 maybe king d2
and then if bishop b3 bishop e8
something like that
it could be
um black is sort of stretched on both
sides of the boards on the board which
pawn does he defend i mean uh
if we should be three
or starting with bishop eight right
even bishop g5 check it could also
happen couldn't it
we really don't see any way out of this
for black
too many good moves for white right
possible and some weak pawns on both
sides of the board and in the middle as
well so um
i don't think there's much today we can
do let's see that is about to make the
move
right he hasn't played king of six yet
yeah this is the current position
but um
white in full control here
bishop g7
and uh well
there's a little trick i know i know
what you're going to say yeah exactly
check discover check
that's right so um
one way that white should not play
but bishop d6 and
bishop c5 should be good enough or
bishop 7
also king king d2 anna also looks quite
good because what does david do with
this bishop with king d2
and then bishop v8 check
i can get to hear him
bishop has to really stay on the a4
bishop a bishop b3 sorry and then bishop
ea check
picks up a pawn
the second pawn
really many options here for white
and of course he has plenty of time on
the clock
uh what about alexey sheriff's game
right
let's have a look and nothing happened
there
the last move from young alex is still
thinking
alexa is down to 14
14 minutes candy to play it he's picking
d2 right
so if bishop f5 he wants to play what
coin to c1
i guess so
but really looks like uh
positions on the verge of
defeat
hmm
uh queen
somewhere
i don't know but if i
promote does it win i mean bishop one
bishop g4
perhaps
check
okay this is a checkmate
that is a checkmate and this one is also
close to checkmate i don't know queen d4
and bishop before i bishop g4
immediately
um
right
queen d4 bishop g4 king runs to f1
what kind of things here yes
after bishop what does white play after
bishop g4
in fact
any move at all
seems to win doesn't it
i don't see how to stop queen e2 but
maybe there is something forced with
queen d4 king e2
this this
tia
queen e4
but i think you'll move this one didn't
that bishop g4 uh straight away
nice line
white has to move his queen and then
queenie two check picks up the while
still mate or just completely lost
okay so that basically means that after
bishop f5 uh queen c1 is not possible
queen b1 is it better or is it the same
maybe it's the same
queen six
it's quite instructive actually just uh
giving up the past form
in order to force a winning attack with
just on the light squares
nice
okay last try queen a what about bishop
f5 queen takes e2 and what about queen
takes e2 how bad is that
this one this one is of course the move
that white should play
this one
because he
may have a check on e7
i thought about quincy one first queen
d1 and then queen c3
all right
queen or starting with coins uh just a
second
still so maybe quinces three first okay
check
so if queen d2 i take and there is no
check on dew seven
right
quinty two quintex b3 simply yes yay and
okay king f1 bishop d3 if kindy one it
comes with the check check so all right
so back is uh take this
almost certainly winning this
he's played bishop g4 he didn't play
bishop five that's interesting
we were looking at bishop f5
he's played bishop g4 maybe he missed
this idea of queening and sacrificing
the pawnee with e1 queen and then
the lines we just looked at
okay he wants queen d5 and quindy one
and then bishop five
yeah
um i don't think it's going to be alex's
day is it today
well let's fight
let's go here
i still you
oh no no no i can take now
it's a block on d4 right if queen d5
check you can block on d4 okay
but
there is of course queen g2 and
h3 h3 was played
and if
played quite fast actually by lexi
yeah but it's a very logical move if we
want to we want to win the spawn
maybe bishop f5 is the right move now
to go back
but then we don't have the idea with u1
and bishop g4 anymore oh that's true
that's true
anything happening on david's game it's
a couple of moves i think anna on the
top board game
what's happening there
are bishop g7
right what did ali razor play i don't
know
oh nothing yet they're still here okay
now i got the most uh bishop d6 bishop
f6 check king h6
and white to play here
or maybe f4 and bishop e5
but he didn't want to play for f4
he wants to refrain from
f4 plane f4
it's uh it's what's this black's next
move in fact
it's almost some kind of zooks fine
much more sparking to play move his
bishop back to g7
so lots of lots of tempting moves here
for white
check and bishop and kinder to your idea
right check on f4
for example yeah king back and then king
d2 that's right
i'll start with king d2
just wins the second point like
everything wins yeah either the h5 pawn
drops or the a4 pawn drops
surely a completely one position here
for
ali reza which will move him up to seven
and a half
out of ten
well a strong recovery uh after
yesterday's
loss
and after today's queen c6 and after
queen c6
which very nearly uh
and could have turned the game around
uh okay andrey sepenko is
somehow he won another pawn
so he's completely winning yes
okay this will uh and alexey sheriff h3
she was played anything yet
no reply yet
looks like young either about to play a
move
going to d5 25 check
king e3
black to play
there is a possibility of check on f3
but i don't know how
dangerous it is
right
what else
maybe he's seeing the forced uh force
line here didn't he
you could check on c5 on it but then
just king d2 space uh yeah
queen cs3 can
see one yeah okay we don't have
we don't have other and then queen a1 to
d1 queen a1 check
we got queen d1 check
yeah and
what has black achieved
not so much
oh let's go all right so um
h2 was a good move
maybe it was the only move
[Music]
uh if he tried to keep the bishop there
and play bishop to f3
right
maybe then the king comes back to
c1 maybe queen a1
he's checked on
e6 queen e6 check
king will come back
and bishops f3 here right
now queen a1 will take on h sorry yes
okay
king d2
all right and now we think bishop f3
should be uh it should be a technical
win for black this position
although he's nothing obviously no black
is no material up but
really dominating position
we expect bishop f3 here
he hasn't played it yet has
no not yet
okay let's try to sacrifice that pawn
queen queen a1
queen h3
because we have to activate the coin
you can't play with the queen on e1
and queen to differ
when the queen when black queen comes to
f1 or h1 uh
i will play bishop
and my idea is to
play queen a7
great
what about after queen a1 if i say so
queen a1 was to block on d4
f check on the d line
no maybe still a half chance here for
alexa to save the game
looks like bishop c5 has been played by
feruxia
okay
and do you think we can expect david to
resign um soon
he's played f4
any half chances for david to save this
game
takes d4
that's right bishop takes d4
so that's now two pawns up for white
take on g3 but then what
maybe he'll swap on g3 and let's move
the bishop away bishop d8
and just play on a little bit more
and then finally the skin details
will come that's going to be another
pawn
that's right
that's going to be too much
it's going to be too much
yeah well david putting a brave face on
it really a bit
no way back i think
yeah it doesn't look
so
alex issue of doing his best to save a
very difficult and awkward position
to keep his chances alive let's say
okay a few rounds ago he said a very
suspicious position against earlier raza
firoza
also was when he played with white
pieces
so
maybe he will also save this one
i like bishop f5 more than bishop g4 now
i don't see
like uh
some clear one
maybe i missed something after bishop f5
i liked your idea before sacrificing the
e-pawn
i'm playing for mate
it was
very effective
but now it maybe doesn't quite work
meanwhile david
they're um
perhaps about to resign and we don't
know
any other games on the low boards anna
that we haven't
all the games um been finishing the
women's tournament bishop d80 looks like
from david
so you didn't take on g3
and yeah the top ball results in the
women's section
uh late india uh draw against uh my
sister
hurricanrana later against elizabeth
patz so late india the winner of
this event yes with eight and a half out
of ten eight and a half out of ten
absolutely uh out of this world that
result
yeah also zuzuner scoring an important
victory for her because now she's on
clear second place but also she got a gm
norm right after this game so
congratulations to zhu zhendra as well
uh joe jenner will face late india
tomorrow in the last round of uh
women's ground swiss and daisy courier
with another win against nana so great
result for her
there's a current up to six and a half
and we bizarre survivor yes another gm
norm and another one from
okay elizabeth pets there also on six
and a half points and those are the
results so far in the open section still
three games going on on the top ten
boards
and um
we think andre yessipenko should be
winning and also arisa for sure is
winning
and alexi shirov has a big battle on his
hands to try and save that game
king d2 there we see from
alireza
and
it's just really hopeless for david here
i'm afraid
he needs to keep defending the a4 pawn
so let's say bishop b3
yeah the only reason number one now
bishop b5 we should be five for example
that's right
and uh
nothing much really the black can do he
can take on g3 but then um white
recaptures
and bishop f4 check is the next move and
then the h5 pawn also drops
no counter play whatsoever for black
and nothing to do
there should be three though
probably bishop e5
yeah well
big favorite to get one of those two
candidates sports disney alireza
yes
leader that's right on seven and a half
points out of ten
assuming he wins this
uh then you have fabiana corona and
gregory opparen with seven out of ten
and
julian gear yeah if he wins if he wins
another player on seven out of ten
so there could be three players could be
three
on seven
we should be five there as we uh
expected
black could give a check on a5 if he
wants we should be 5 check he's taken on
g3
we assume f
pawn will take f2 ticks
and then white threatens bishop f4 check
and the h5 pawn
will fall
and really black cannot do anything
about that
it's even difficult to come up with some
lines
right
yeah well he can check on a5 next move
maybe
f takes g3
of course keeps his pawns they are
protecting each other the g pawn
protects his protects the h4 pawn
bishop a5 check right
trying to get his bishop back to d1
maybe to try and hang on to this h5 pawn
but just king 200 yeah king e2 now
i think any more with a king yeah
king c1
so that there are no checks no more
checks and prevents the bishop coming to
d1
and next move white will play bishop f4
check
king will have to retreat and the bishop
on e8 will take on h5 and that becomes
three extra pawns for white
and really and truly there's nothing
much left for black here
good game from um
from both players and really just that
dramatic moment with queen c6
in the run up to the first time control
which uh
surely arrester missed he must have
missed that move
so we're expecting um
david to resign i think here
or will you play a move
okay still thinking yeah
well
he has time to think on his clock at
least
let's quickly check alexa's game
so it was uh
queen d5 king to e3 and bishop f5 now
right
so kind of like the lines we were
looking at before but he's
white has the extra move with h2h3
any chances for alexi
yeah it's not it's not hopeless
definitely
more chances than in david's camp let's
try queen takes e2 for example anna what
would happen okay queen dix then check
king has to come back check check he has
to come back
and
likely queen to c3
right which uh yes
like the line we had before isn't it
but with the pawn on h2 yes
and such a position any chances to save
yeah maybe
maybe some chances to hold this
g4 maybe
that's not a bishop d3
that's some
bishop d54 g5
right
no it doesn't look so hopeless no
is there anything better
uh so uh bishop five this is the current
position right okay uh we discussed
queen to e2
kin to e2 doesn't look good yeah bishop
c2 if king takes bishop takes yeah
threatens m81 queen d3
okay
well also possible
maybe queen is six
and then to take uh queen
aquinas okay the same as
david and then with the handshake on
board one another so david howell has
resigned that game it's a win to alireza
and he moves once again to the top of
this event clear leader
seven and a half out of ten
and continues his great run of form
a quick
discussion there
it's interesting which moment they are
discussing and
um
i wonder
yeah david he
it's like he completely missed some idea
yeah they're both sort of smiling there
maybe we'll have an interview anna with
alireza that would be very nice
to hear his thoughts on the game
and sadly for david uh
yeah he lost i think after four
consecutive wins and suddenly uh
found himself in a tie for first place
on top board with uh chances to fight
for one of those two candidate spots
yeah but after this defeat i think he
has no ups that's it
so hard luck to david and uh
well well done for putting up a big
fight
still a great tournament even after this
defeat that's right
his performance is definitely higher
than his rating
uh but after getting so close of course
you want to fight for more of course
yeah so inevitably here you have a bit
disappointment there
and
especially that chance with after queen
c6 which you found
maybe uh had he not played bishop v8 but
the other lines we were looking at
his position was uh
at least equal maybe even some advantage
possibly we're not sure
but there we are local time 7 25 p.m
and most of the games have finished but
some are still going on
so maybe let's check alexa's game and
let's see if we can have an interview
with uh
with uh alireza ferruga
and what he will say
about
this moment when he played knight h6 and
half he felt after queen c6 that's right
it'd be nice to hear that so um alexis
shirov can he save this game
this is also a very important game of
course it is definitely for the pairings
for the top pairings and for these two
players absolutely
if you young he could win he gets into a
tie for second place
so of course alexei can't win this one
but uh for yu yang gi it's a really
important game
because if he wins this one he's entire
for a second and he gets white tomorrow
very likely
yes so his chances are actually
increasing a lot
that's right a huge game of him tomorrow
king takes e2 has been played by
alexey so he's at least eliminated this
terrifying pawn on e2
of course he's going to lose c2 check
has happened
no you can't picking f1 because the
bridge takes h3 and then mate yeah so
well bishop is three the only
the only move and bishop is replayed
okay
milan i
i believe we have an interview so i'm
over to you yes we do thank you very
much we have alireza ferrugia with us
who just won a very game against david
howell and is
again alone in first place lead in the
tournament
let's start from the game in the
beginning it seems you spent more time
in the opening than david hall which
usually isn't the case with david what
went wrong for you what why is was that
yeah he chose the very
very solid opening
obviously it was played a lot in this
champions tour and he was commentating
all the games so
um but yeah he this is very solid
opening i was just choosing whether to
go very sharp or
just the way i play very solid and
wait for my chances so this was the
reason after you created that chance
with knight h6 and you entered the
better position you hastily played queen
f3 to which
hal responded with quincy's second i am
they do
no of course i missed this queen c6 and
it was just a shock to me because
normally it's very awkward this uh very
weird this setup of
meeting in the background when you're
upon on history but okay bishop is on g3
so it says it was a shock but i was
lucky i had this bishop c2 and i was
keeping the game going at least and it
was not suddenly losing so
after after that queen f3 and queen c6
there was a
visible change in your mood and your
your appearance in your face and you
then started walking
down the hall how do you you were
clearly annoyed how did you calm
yourself
uh after that um i was lucky because he
saw when i made this next move he
suddenly played the wrong move i think
and i managed to calm myself down but
when i saw i had this bishop c2 and i am
at least keeping the game going
and i'm not losing
right away i was
a little happy and that's why
i was not so annoyed and during the
rounds we saw you pacing down the down
the playing hall up and down and looking
at other games
when you're when you're pacing for the
hallway do you think of your own game
only or do you actually look at other
games analyze think about them as well
or think about something else no of
course it's interesting the games are
going all of them are very
good quality so it's always interesting
to follow but yeah normally
the game itself is very difficult and
you should always focus on your game so
okay and finally like again with seven
and a half out of ten you're alone in
the lead how confident do you feel that
you will reach the candidates
i am
i think my chances get very low after
yesterday last but i'm happy i managed
to
get the win today against david because
he played very good until here he had
four wins in a row so he was in a very
good mood
so this win was important but okay in
general i think
i have good chances tomorrow and we will
see
thank you very much and good luck thank
you thank you
yes thank you milan there for that
interview and uh ali reza furuja there
as we've just seen uh
beating david howell uh he says
as we sort of figured that he did miss
queen c6 but uh he found the only move
really bishop c2 afterwards he was
in a way fortunate let's say that he um
the position was still
playable and unclear
and um it was interesting to him his
thoughts on that wasn't it yeah of
course
um anna we've still got this very
important game here alexis show of
trying to save this end game against yu
yang yi but we're gonna have a quick
break
and then we'll be right back um to see
if alexia kennedy'd save this game and
uh
let's see
we'll see you all very very soon
[Music]
uh and welcome back everyone it's live
broadcast from riga latvia around 10.
most of the games have been finished but
there is still one game in progress on
one of the top boards is actually board
number four between alexis cheryl and
julian giem also very important game for
the standings and for tomorrow's round
and for the
candidate tickets that's right
so their confirmation of alien alireza's
victory with white today over david howe
uh that keeps him or puts him out in
front by half a point seven and a half
out of ten and um we just had an
interesting interview with him
and uh that game had a very dramatic
moment didn't it where david played that
move queen c6
so alexis shiroff against yu yang yi is
the only game in the top ten
still
in progress
and those
are the top women's results
yeah all the games in the women's
section have been finished so uh here we
see the top
uh
top boards result late in here made a
draw against my sister harika naval
elizabeth perez another drone
zhu zhen are very important to win
against la la javert israelis so late in
jai is already the winner of the
tournament congratulations to late india
but uh zhu zhang also fantastic result
being on clear second
uh after today's round and jim norm yes
that's right um
[Music]
okay so here we see um alexei there
of course with white against uh yu yangi
now ana let's have a look at the latest
moves
just talk us through what happened
so queen d2
queen b3 g4 has been played right
this looks like a better version for a
white comparing to what we discussed
absolutely i think alexa might save this
game you know
uh bishop e6 queen to d6 finally finally
this queen
is active again
and suddenly white has real chances of
counter play
with moves like g5 bishop d4 and so on
screen siren check queen jack of course
yep so um
even bishop's fire queen of f8 idea
right
that's true bishop c5 and queen f8 would
in fact be checkmate yeah so suddenly um
from such a passive and unpleasant
uncomfortable position that alexi had
now
i mean sure he's upon down but uh he's
got active play at last
queen d6 the last move played
and under which move are they on
uh more number 53 53 seven moves from
the from the
next time control would move 60 and the
clock time something like nine and a
half minutes for yu yang yi and six and
a half minutes for alexi
but
suddenly uh
the black victory is by no means uh
certain is it anna
it doesn't look easy
i mean with the pawn on it too it felt
like black should win somehow but uh
after this pawn
uh is gone it's not clear anymore
absolutely not no and
i think alexis is going to save this
really
i really do um
h3 was a nice move that he played wasn't
it
some time ago now
and maybe your move bishop f5 was the
key rather than bishop g4 at that moment
when you young you played
you couldn't find defense after bishop
f5
so maybe black was winning earlier
but white had a really pleasant position
in the beginning of the game and in the
middle game
so maybe it was a big fight was it a big
struggle this year big fight
all this came from a very interesting
opening starting with sicilian second
move knight is three d6 d4
queen takes it and the knight d1 to e3
was a nice maneuver i remember and h4 a4
followed by long castles yeah
so i believe that in the beginning alexa
was disappointed that
he lost his advantage but
then in the end he may be happy that he
absolutely well if he saved this game
he'll be delighted with a draw from this
game um given the position he had even
just 10 moves ago
so
there we are
to play
it's actually quite difficult even to
suggest someone for black
what is he going to play i wonder
so
um he would have got to seven points you
young if he'd won this game
or alexey of course yeah if he won that
game or if alexey won that game they
could they still had
very good chances
to qualify to the candidates if things
go
also
well tomorrow
uh but
if this game ends in a draw then
then of course their chances
decrease a lot i mean and on seven
points we have fabiano on seven points
uh ali restaurant seven and a half
fabiano on seven also
your pardon operating on seven points is
surprised to see him so high up but he's
having a really fantastic event and
beating nikita vichygov today with the
black pieces
and anyone else on seven no no it's just
those two
only those two because the other games
ended in a draw
so presumably our parent will go
up to play uh
with white pieces
and he's kind of in a must-win situation
because with the draw i think he said
tie breaks are
not that great right
right
interesting
and who i wonder would fabiano play
we don't know do we
so um you young leader has played i
think queen c4 check
it looks like indeed
for when i'll play against someone over
six and a half points
quite a few players on i think six and a
half
[Music]
a lot of people are six and a half and
also many people who won today with uh
five and a half points right
possibly uh
alexander pretzka i don't think has
played fabiano yet
that might be um
the pairing but this game is still in
progress anyway so obviously uh young
you trying to win
um
there ought to be uh winning chances
let's say
let's see what uh alexi plays
but certainly black's advantage seems to
have evaporated enough from what it was
uh with our pawn on e2
king f2 is it king f2 qf2 looks normal
sure
king of two why not
maybe we can check like
very quickly what's happening on the
other boards and we can keep the camera
okay on this board yeah uh so which
other games are still in progress
this one
we have seen many
okay
but not not too many
and this really all to finish in a draw
in this game we think
it seems like white is trying to play
for a win but
but not easy
okay
uh
this is the game we didn't see
wow look at that we didn't see at all
earlier so it's between the robert of
heineken and
uh
jorge
corey
whose sister is playing in the women's
event
and doing so well
so maybe another draw here
right it looks uh it looks pretty level
isn't it
yeah a draw looks likely though
all right any other games
against donchenko
so the question is if there is perpetual
check right clearly black trying to draw
maybe queen a5 yes then just keep on
checking actually they're having many
checks before the players got there
right
so this is the position looks quite uh
likely to enter the draw then let's see
but after queen a5 can b2 is the only
move
okay now the only maybe king b3 queen b5
and now queen to a2 but then queen
e2 and it's more or less the same
position right many many checks and the
rooks can't
really block
okay good chances to draw then for
donchenko
guyan against
petrol what about the pawn end game
because it's the only chance
it takes yeah this c pawn otherwise is
going through
uh f3 f3 followed by g4 that's nice yeah
f3
and if pawn takes pawn then g4
and white makes it past h pawn oh yeah
this is winning it's winners doesn't it
yeah but if k6
takes
there
okay yeah
this one we don't know about close to
winning
sure
okay next game
so plenty of games still going on emma
yeah
greater son against kovalev wow look at
all those three points for the piece
uh what is playing for the win right c4
c5 the last move and we have
some something on
the alexa sheriff game a move
or two has been played
queen a2 check
and what's the idea of king g3 bishop
the fire d5 is that even possible
but it's not the checkmate after queen
yet right
so
uh if
will start to play for win at some
points you know
sure we play queen e7
stranger things have happened
alexis with the pen in his hands yes
which we've seen him do before
quite an unusual habit
i really don't think he's going to lose
this game
in alexa we trust
sure
and
yeah so why not king g3 here
it looks fine king g3
because if bishop d5 i can check
yeah basically fire just check and black
has to bring his bishop back
so there's no danger really
yeah no it can turn
bishop c5 i think
before if check we go here
and there is no checkmate
he's paid king g3
no that's what i'm saying the game could
i mean i don't think it will but it is
one consult to see lions which
win for white
king g3
maybe
queen
let's see what uh black has played has
he played a move
queen defy maybe
our queen defensive f7 was
played queen eight bishop f7 now uh
bishop
c5 yeah
indeed what's wrong with bishop c5 here
i suppose black has g5
no he doesn't
have g5
i keep playing g5 you had another mode
that
is also very logical
um but bishop c5
maybe h6 yeah it sucks
so g5 played he's played g5 right
and which move number is this anna
57 57 still
three or four minutes to go
like has four moves to play here
what should he play queen e6 or
something maybe just time to make a draw
for black
i think
even time to have dinner
well
it can still go wrong can't it
but he will be disappointed uh young you
not to win this game assuming this does
end in a draw
yeah in the end he'll be he'll be
disappointed
but looking uh
at how the game developed
and
in the beginning i think he was not so
happy about his position
yes alexey of course
he was the last player i wasn't anna to
enter or or to be uh included in the
tournaments let's see
alexis sheriff
and he's had a brilliant event
i think he was
yeah he was offered the place that he
didn't want
because of all these lockdown rules
right okay and then somehow in the very
end he decided to play and he has a
great event yeah
so um yangi then down to about two
two minutes twenty or so he still has
four moves to make
i think he just should steal this game
to draw somehow
genius players are usually fighting
until the very end right
but
they are ready to play any position like
seven hours eight hours doesn't matter
so what can you do here i mean uh
i don't see any winning chances left
okay after queen e6 well sure
i mean he can play move like that
we may take with the pawn and then queen
this play
for win no with bishop d4 that's right
why alexa may do that
or queen a7 or something like that
there are still queen cs3 so it's not
that dangerous he's played queen e6 look
queen is explained that's pay queen is
six yeah well
as we said he needs to just make sure he
doesn't lose
so if white takes and then
bishop
to d4 right
takes then
king moose
is that a dead draw or not
okay why it doesn't need to go there
oh still some winning chances for black
yeah now it's unclear because the king
can penetrate and then
queen e6
maybe alexa will play
one of these other moves that we're
talking about not to swap the queens
okay here we go if we want to go to the
opposite color bishop's end game maybe
this one yeah and after b3 we take
oh because the kings will have six but
right yeah i mean
still uh black has chances here with
king f5
so there is absolutely no need to trade
the queens he's taken on f6 check
okay but but i think he will keep the
queens on the board right
queen takes f6
and the big choice for me is maybe queen
e4
centralize
queen d7 also
he's moved his screen away somewhere
queen c5 queen so far okay
right well threatening bishop d4 of
course
and a bit of time pressure here for
black and their own move on a move 58
was that
i don't think it's like a back time
pressure yeah
still one minute and a half for two
moves
i mean queen c3 is an immediate draw if
white just swaps queens and plays bishop
d4 check yeah
which may happen
i think that's a fair chance of that is
what's going to happen questions
bishop d4 check what happens
and then run the king to h5 yes
okay
and then
either queen fha or queen e7
why did he play i'm not sure what he's
played
queen f5 okay queen f5 okay
is that the move you said
well white could trade and play bishop
b6 couldn't he
yeah but then again the same
he's traded he's done that and bishop b6
for this or this takes and i think we
can call this a draw and if we start
running with the king but okay of course
in the previous line
was not that close
so just
well this this
came to f3
and i might in time like it's to d2 or
but this is uh
even without the a4 pawn it would still
be a draw
right
a bishop b6 this was played he's played
this right
so um
[Music]
a big save from alexey
from what must have been a lost position
but probably these two players
without uh
without chances enough for that uh
candidate spot i don't know unless
somebody
well maybe depending on time breaks and
so on
this is all happens maybe for lexi
somehow
yeah
if he wins tomorrow and
if the other results go his way
he may still have a chance because he
may have a good tiebreaker yes he always
played on the top
so we really i think this game will end
and
not many moose king e6
bishop c3
and whites will bring his king to e3
and draw
so tomorrow's pairings and that'll be
interesting to see um
see how they turn out but it looks like
our pardon will be playing against ali
raza
correct
and it's completely unclear
whole play against fabiano
right
you know it may be funny because whoever
gets her fabiana it will be both
you know pleasant and unpleasant
unpleasant uh because facing corona is
black pieces maybe not the best thing
not like your dream but on the other
hand it's uh the only chance
to beat uh fabiano and then to fight
to fight for this kind of spots
that's right yeah
so um
and you know last rounds of course
everyone knows the last round of
tournaments
strange things happen sometimes and uh
results go completely the uh the way
you'd least expect
so much pressure on the players
it's kind of an all or nothing situation
especially here not just the prize money
but as we've kept saying two candidate
spots
at stake so um
a very unusual situation
by the way they're also fighting for the
grand prix sports i don't know how many
players are qualified to the grand prix
but it's definitely more than two so
they are not only fighting for the
candid sport but also for for the grand
prix sports
have they reached move 60 not yet anna
yeah they have i'm sorry
now the 63
alexa to play here
any chances for black gunner or is it
just a dead draw
no no chances i believe
really this should be um
finishing very very soon on the half
point
each
a big fight of course
and certainly alexa i think will be
relieved
um
to have uh helped this game
i think draw was the least expected
result of this one
both players played for a win yeah
both players had chances here just to
recap um
just before we go anna the uh results
there those are the top 10 boards of the
women's event and uh
latinxie
eight and a half points out of ten
fantastic chess and
brilliant performance from her and she's
already won this event with around to go
and important wins for zuchinner who
makes a gm nom and daisy corey also
there
and bibisara also making a gm nom by
beating paulina shivalova today so
excellent result for her
and tomorrow anna that's the schedule
uh yes so i think we are ending this
stream for today but tomorrow we'll be
back at the same time 2 p.m local time
or
1 p.m central european time so uh thanks
for watching thanks for supporting
thanks for your questions thanks to our
production team for our amazing
production amazing production team
for helping us with with this show so
see you tomorrow and uh the last round
everything will be decided there
want to play chess online or learn how
to improve
join us at the number one chess
destination in the world chess.com with
hundreds of thousands of people playing
at any moment you'll quickly find a game
with someone at your level whether
you're a total beginner or a grandmaster
you can play games at any pace against
friends other members or one of our many
computer personalities
chess.com makes improving fun and easy
sharpen your game with tactics puzzlers
and enhance your strategy with our
videos and lessons by top masters
learn from your own games with
chess.com's easy to use analysis tool
regardless of your skill level chess.com
has all you need to take your game to
the next level chess.com is your go-to
source for chess news live coverage of
tournaments events and everything in
between
experiencechess.com anytime and anywhere
whether you're at home on your computer
or on the go with our mobile apps
signing up is free and easy so what are
you waiting for join chess.com today
[Music]
you